-I think we should
get Benny a car.
-Is this her asking
or you asking?
-Me.
No, she's been home
three months now.
I think she's demonstrated
enough that we can trust her
-I'm not getting her a car
so the next time she runs of
with some [bleep] idiot,
I got to drive up
to New Hampshire
and bail her out of trouble.
-That's unfair.
-No, you know what's unfair?
Is you being all the way up he
ass ever since she's been home
Jesus Christ, leave her alone.
Ever since you threw out
your mother [bleep]
you've been stalking around here
like the fates in Camelot.
Get a [bleep] hobby,
for Christ's sake.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Kevin Bacon.
And I'm really glad
we showed that clip,
because it would be impossible
for that scene to take place
in that era in Boston
without at least two beeps
-Oh, whoa.
Well, when it comes to
my character,
there was a time in the firs
season when I had to,
for some reason,
loop every single curse
for markets
that would not have allowe
any kind of cursing at all
And it was next to impossible.
I mean, if there's not like 18
F-words a scene, I add them.
-Right.
-Just because it's become
so much part of the characte
and so much part of, you know,
who he is.
-And so for people
who don't know,
that means you're going in
you're watching it,
and you're looping in
a different word for...
-Yes.
-...[bleep]
-Yeah, right.
-See if the censors are here
-Exactly, right.
And it's hard to come up
with them after a while.
So they get somebody else
to write them,
and they're just
hilariously bad.
You know what I mean?
It's just --
It's a losing battle.
-The bummer is when the people
from those markets
see a show like that
and then they go to Boston
for the first time
and they're expecting everyone
when they're mad at them,
to be like, "Oh, funnel cake!"
Then they hear the real
language, they're like,
"This is not
what I expected it to be."
-Yeah, let's face it,
no one from that market
is watching the show anyway.
-Hey, um, you went out
and did this.
You bought a 1969 Ford Bronco.
-Yeah, yeah.
God bless YouTube.
It's three on the tree.
Are you familiar with that
-No, I'm not familiar.
-You know,
a standard transmission,
you have a stick shift, right?
-Yeah.
-I know how to drive
a stick shift,
but the actual shifter
is on the steering column,
which is something
that I'd never driven.
So I was literally watchin
YouTube, you know,
"How do you drive --"
So the guy pulls it up and drops
it off in the backyard.
I'm like, "Oh, that's great.
I wish I knew how to move it
so that I could
get it out of the way,
we could get our other car."
-Well, yeah, do please
keep it off the roads.
-Well, yeah.
No, I would never drive it
-You -- We've talked in the past
when you're here
about how you made a lot o
these incredibly iconic movies
early in your career --
"Animal House"
right out of the gate
and then "Diner"
with Barry Levinson.
-"Diner," yeah.
-Which when you look at
that cast, you know,
a lot of people were makin
their first or second movie.
It's really amazing.
Was that a fun experience?
'Cause it certainly is
a fun movie to watch.
-It was a great experience
We've had a couple of reunions
you know, in the past.
Do you smoke marijuana, weed
-I have, yeah.
-You have in the past, yeah.
Mary Jane?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Well, be careful.
It's a gateway drug.
-Yeah, you smoke enough,
next thing you know,
you're buying a car.
-Yeah.
-Buying a Ford Bronco.
-Exactly.
-Don't even know
how to drive it.
-Don't even know how
to drive it, exactly.
Well, you know, different people
react differently to it.
You know, I'm okay
as long as I'm in, like,
a super, super safe
kind of situation.
-Yeah, like with Mickey Rourke
-Not with Mickey Rourke.
No, no, no.
You know, I need to be lik
in bed or something --
Like, work, like,
never, never --
-I'm 100% like you.
-You're not high right now
-No, I'm not high right now.
But, like, watching a movie,
yeah, safe in a room.
-Yeah, exactly.
Otherwise, I can get
a little paranoid.
So, weed, terrible.
Alcohol, terrible.
Any kind of drug,
it just doesn't go with work
in my opinion.
So we had a day off
while we're doing "Diner."
And it's definitely a day of
on the schedule.
So another actor -- I don't want
to mention his name
'cause there's drugs involved --
Danny Stern says to me,
"Do you want to go to the movies
and get high?
We'll get high
and we'll go to the movies."
So I was like,
"Yeah, definitely.
We're not working today.
Awesome."
Now, keep in mind,
there's no cellphones, right
-Yep.
-So nobody knows where we are,
and we're in Baltimore
in the middle of the afternoon
watching whatever movie would be
the popular movie back then.
I can't even
do the math on that.
But -- And all of a sudden
it's dark.
We're watching the movie.
And I hear someone go, "Is
Kevin Bacon here in the theater?
Is there a Kevin Bacon
in the theater?"
I mean, literally,
I [bleep] my pants.
I was like, "Oh, my God,
what is happening?"
And sure enough, the productio
had -- they needed me.
And I don't think
they needed Danny.
So he's cracking --
he's hysterical,
you know, laughing at the fact
that I've got to go back.
And they had somehow
tracked us down.
Somebody had told somebody
that told somebody
that we were gonna
go to the movies,
and they went to every singl
movie theater in Boston --
in Baltimore and found us.
And I went back to work.
And, you know, I was fine.
It turned out that the scene
was just me
walking in the background
or something like that.
Plus the adrenaline just
straightened me right up.
-It is -- I mean,
that is the nightmare.
If you're someone who gets
paranoid smoking weed,
the nightmare is
someone will come in
and literally scream your name
-Absolutely.
Absolutely.
It was -- It was the worst thing
that could possibly happen
at that moment.
-Well, I'm very glad
it did not affect the work
And it is such a delight
to have you.
-Affect the work?
You saw that performance.
-It was amazing!
It was amazing,
and it stands the test of time
And I did think
you were a little stoned.
The second season
of "City on a Hill"
premieres March 28th
on Showtime.
We'll be right back with Retta